la congélation est un des meilleurs
moyens de conserver un aliment mais
selon la méthode il se forme des
cristaux de glace plus ou moins gros qui
endommage la texture quand on voit
décongelé le mal est un peu fait en
quelque sorte parce que c'est ce qui va
arriver c'est que on va voir les
cristaux de glace qui se sont formés
pendant la congélation qui vont fondre
en fondant les christophe briser les
cellules et faire éclater et va causer
une perte d'eau une paire de textures ce
pour ça que des fois les légumes 10
heures du conte je la perds un peu que
là où tu te pas très appétissant ou du
petit jules qui se forme dans la viande
et des congères
c'est pourquoi il faut savoir comment
bien décongeler nos aliments pour ne pas
les abîmer ou nous mettre à risque sur
notre travail anne marie ce qu'on a
c'est le résultat de nos différentes
décongélation had marie a utilisé de la
viande hachée pour illustrer les impacts
sur les aliments de différentes
techniques de décongélation
on a ici la dangereuse technique sur le
comptoir et qu'ils aient pris 5h20 c'est
vraiment des conseillers ou faux faux
pas du tout peur
le danger c'est la prolifération des
bactéries dans les aliments qui
nécessitent d'être réfrigérée comme les
poissons et les viandes centrale exemple
de fâcher
ben ils pourraient avoir facilement
emile bactéries par gramme de boeuf
hachée ou c'est tout à fait normal mais
si on laisse le boeuf haché sur le
comptoir pendant trois heures 20 à la
fin on passe de mille à un million
autre technique de décongélation le
micro ondes
l'idée c'est de mettre le poids des oui
c'est ça qui compte des grands jeunes et
là c'est parti
c'est souvent ça qu'on va obtenir après
la décongélation micro ans donc on est
même encore un petit peu congelée au
centre mais c'est vraiment subtil mais
on voit alors que les côtés en fait on
one on cuisine on gagne du temps mais on
perd en texture cette viande décrites au
métro on aiderait macro chanteuse c'est
pop les halles
on peut aussi cuire à feu doux sans
décongeler au four ou sur la cuisinière
on arrive le soir on oublie décongelé on
a bien lâché pur esprit donc on veut la
paix directement congelé puis de 36 nous
sommes décongeler si rapide mais encore
là on y perd côté textures ça faisait
est très sucré comme bien la fit l'objet
dans dés mijoteuse puis le réflexion on
a même des pièces de viandes congelées
dans la mijoteuse danger ou pas danger
quand même la règle générale faut qu'on
ait atteint une température de 63 degrés
ou centre en 12 heures en général pour
une pièce de viande
donc ça c'est quand même assez difficile
à faire du sur une pièce de viande
congelée dans une mijoteuse donc l'idéal
c'est vraiment à décongeler avant la
mi-temps mijoteuse les prochaines
technique de décongélation sont à
privilégier façon lente déposé l'aliment
des gelées dans la partie inférieure de
votre frigo
ç'a pris 23 heures de décongélation très
long et en général sont boudés convié
une pièce de viande quoi que ce soit
faut le mettre la veille pour le
cuisiner le lendemain mais une façon
d'accélérer vraiment rapidement deux
doublés en fait la vitesse de
décongélation
on peut mettre votre viande dans un plat
de dos c'est deux fois plus rapide donc
par efficace qu'on voit la texture est
très similaire donc très bons résultats
il est aussi possible de plonger dans
l'eau froide l'aliment dans son
emballage en maintenant une circulation
avec un filet d'eau froide
si vous décongeler à l'eau courante
pendant une heure le temps de temps
acceptable pour cette décongélation la
technique est aussi recommandée pour les
saumons fumés ou autres produits
emballés sous vide ça vaut décongeler
environ dix quinze minutes c'est
vraiment très très rapide mais la
prudence s'impose si vous décidez de
faire dégeler au frigo des aliments
emballés sous vide quand on a un produit
souvent il n'y a pas d'air
cai a pas d'air et
on est au frigo une bactérie extrêmement
dangereux qui s'appelle clostridium
botulinum qui est pathogène qui crée une
toxine qui s'appelle la botuline donc il
faut absolument ouvrir le sachet par
exemple quand on voit le décompte île
pendant plusieurs heures au frigo c'est
que on veut briser le vide et 15 oxygène
cette bactérie yooz met du pipeau a créé
pas de toxines est-ce qu'on peut
congeler quelque chose qui était des
congés ci est encore partiellement
congelés on pourrait leur convenir
si la majeure partie de l'aliment est
encore congelés shell a indiqué
l'extérieur n'a pas encore été exposées
à des températures trop élevées pour que
ce soit dangereux
messi a complètement des conflits il
faut absolument le cuir à ce moment là
parce que ils voient étais-je demain il
va avoir été trop à risque
que doit-on faire lorsqu il y à un bris
du congélateur ou une panne de courant
si elle vous avez un congélateur par
exemple tombeau où était indépendant ses
congélateurs luck sont bien remplies
vont garder les aliments congelés
pendant 48 heures si vous voudrez pas le
vertige à moitié plein on parle de 12
heures et pour un congélateur qui se
trouve au dessus de réfugiés la parole
c'est quelqu'un d'assez bouquin f k si
le congélateur et plus chaud que quatre
degrés celsius pas de chance à prendre
on jette tout en résumé ne jamais
décongeler d'aliments température pièce
privilégier la décongélation au frigo ou
sur l'eau froide